we are all aware of the formula speed
multiplied by time is equal to distance
this gives us the distance if we want to
find the speed we transpose time to the
other side and if we want to find the
time we transpose P to the other side a
good way to remember this is by
remembering this triangle with a T we
have speed and time at the bottom and
distance on top if we want to find the
time it will be D over s if speed it
will be d over T if we want the distance
it will be s times D really simple isn't
it how are these parameters given to us
speed is given as a rate something like
10 kilometers per hour say we travel at
this rate for two hours what will be the
distance that is covered it will be 10
times 2 or 20 kilometers observe that
the units are also working out perfectly
kilometers over hours multiplied by
hours hours get cancelled and what
remains is kilometers with this formula
if we are given any two parameters we
can easily find the third units of time
and distance are straightforward but
units of speed can get interesting it
can be provided to us as kilometers per
hour
or sometimes even meters per second and
it is important to keep in mind that the
units of all three parameters must be in
sync
it would be incorrect to say 10 meters
per second multiplied by 2 hours is 20
but 10 meters per second times 2 seconds
will equal 20 meters that's because
seconds get cancelled so sometimes we
may need to convert the speed from
kilometers per hour to meters per second
or vice versa
let's say we have been given the speed
in kilometers per hour
how would you convert it to meters per
second pause the video and think about
it
how would you convert kilometers per
hour to meters per second if we multiply
the value in km/h with 5 over 18 we will
get the answer in meters per second yes
that's how easy it is let's see why we
know that one kilometer is 1000 meters
and how many seconds is one hour equal
to one hour is 60 minutes and one minute
is 60 seconds 60 times 60 will be 3600
seconds now we simply reduce this
fraction to its simplest form we cancel
the two zeros 2 times 5 is 10 and 2
times 18 is 36 so this is equivalent to
5 over 18 meters per second yes one
kilometer per hour is the same as 5 over
18 meters per second in time speed and
distance problems we need to keep the
unit's in mind so based on what we
learnt why don't you try converting 54
kilometers per hour to meters per second
as one kilometer per hour is the same as
5 over 18 meters per second we multiply
this with 5 over 18 to get the answer in
meters per second
18 times 3 is 54 and 3 times 5 is 15 54
kilometers per hour is equal to 15
meters per second and it goes without
saying that to convert from meters per
second to kilometers per hour we have to
multiply by 18 over five this topic is
best understood with examples we will
cover more than 20 different types of
examples in the coming session